[Music]  Sally Field is playing matchmaker  between Olympic figure skater Adam  rippen  and her son who knew according to a  tweet from her 30 year-old son Sam the  actress is trying to set him up with  everyone's new crush figure skater Adam  rippin from the US men's figure skating  team Sam tweeted just some really  helpful advice from my mom on how to  deal with my Olympic crush along with a  screenshot of a text she sent him quote  Sam he's insanely pretty find a way  field later retweeted her youngest son's  post epically tagging ribbon to be sure  he gets the message we just sort of did  that by the seat of our pants rippin who  is one of the first openly gay US male  athletes to qualify for the Winter  Olympics has yet to publicly respond  [Music]